People often call IT professionals about network connection problems.
But many problems are easy to fix without help.
First, reconnect any loose CAT5 cable connections.
Next, investigate IP address issues.
This group of numbers allows communication on the internet.
Renewing your DHCP fixes most IP problems.
Next, check the router.
The router links LANs to the internet.
Make sure the router's configuration is correct.
WLANs have other problems.
Interference often blocks their wireless signals.
But there is a simple solution.
Just move the router away from walls and metals.
Finally, cycle the network.
Turn all equipment off for a full minute and then restart.